[Music]
welcome to your fist kids I'm link and
I'm Rhett this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting is just the two of us
greetings people of the future thank you
for listening to this archaic form of
entertainment audio entertainment known
as a podcast specifically this one
called ear biscuits the show I think a
little less note called rhett and Link
2014 time capsule yeah to give a little
context here to those of you listening
in the present and those of you
listening in to in the future
I guess those of you who are the only
one listening is present right well and
then when I'm doing this you're
listening in the press into in the
short-term future and those of you
listening in in a long-term future to
different groups of people and then all
them in between this is how this works
we thought that it would be appropriate
and you know almost mandated by us
personally important to take stock of
the way that we are seeing the world
these days not not as personally but the
way the world is in terms of technology
style what we're like at this point
trying to create an audio record to
basically create an audio time capsule
yeah inspired in part by our kind of
off-the-cuff conversation with Hank
green right where somehow we were
speaking to people 2,000 years 2,000
years in the 2000 zeod like free the
year 4000 something yes so what we're
doing it that people would be listening
in 2,000 years 3 pompous I mean this one
is just simply a 10-year capsule oh
really
yeah I think 2024 because it's easy to
remember is it's not too much time to
for people to forget so those of you who
are listening in 2014
thank you by the way for taking this as
it was given to you as it was intended
make a note right now keep listening by
the way ok listen to the whole thing but
I want you to go ahead and get out your
phones because you
to forget this or take out your computer
or what I guess you're listening this on
your phone or your computer they might
need to tattoo themselves we know what
kind of device are they gonna have the
same phone is it gonna pour it over
they're gonna go from the cloud I assume
if you put a reminder if you put a
reminder in your phone for January first
20 24 less it doesn't have to be an
exact ten years let's just say the New
Year 2024 because we don't even know
what date this podcast this episode's
gonna come out necessarily you put a
reminder in there and it just needs to
say listen to that old ear biscuits if
you can find it and hopefully hopefully
you will be able to find it maybe you
know you should you go back to the
reminder and put the URL it'll still be
it'll still work
all you gotta do is think about it 20
years from now 10 years from now 10
years now I gotta just think about the
podcast and you'll start hearing it in
your brain right now that would be a
Google search will be thinking right so
you'll be thinking it now so that this
is gonna be important well this is going
to be it this is gonna be fun hopefully
this team this is gonna be something
it'll be laughable for those of you
listening in 2024 you're already
laughing I'll listen to how they talk
oh they speak English in those weird
accents always now are we listening to
this back to because are we still alive
well I mean I certainly hope we are I
mean if we mean that's a thought if we
live to the proper age or the expected
age and we does certainly will be alive
but certainly 10 years from now hope so
there could be an accident but maybe
that brings us to our next rhettandlink
only your biscuit which is the eulogy
your biscuit self eulogy I don't mean to
get so morbid here let's keep it light
let's keep it listen let's keep it real
I think it's important as we talk about
these things we've got a few categories
that we're gonna kind of conversate
through here yes it's important that
we're honest there's we don't need to
candy-coat or sugarcoat 2014 2014 it is
what it is it is 4 it is what it is and
here it is and we're just describing it
anticipating that 10 years from now
we're just gonna just cat
call at you know so really Laurel and
Hardy living in an old on Laurel and
Ward's do you want to start with comedy
that's an interesting state of comedy
what in 2014 everything we've set up to
this point was humorous see I'm candy
Cody
I'm already sugar cut well it was
intended to be we think that were funny
we think that we're we're thinking that
this is a funny concept in 24 we think
that we're funny now we think that
people will find this funny even what
works they have a good sense of humor
right now we think is funny we think
this is funny we think that we're being
funny right now
yeah in 2014 yeah ten years from now of
course not this is first of all maybe we
should set two reminders because 10
years from now you know what you should
you you know what it should be a
recurrent reminder and it should say
every 10 years oh I think that's
probably an option because the Sabrina
this is an incremental thing because I'd
really don't think that the sense of
humor of evil is gonna be that different
in ten years but a hundred years you
know - after ten reminders you'll
probably be dead a so maybe eight
reminders from now I think people get
what we're doing we should probably just
start doing it because we've taken a lot
of time just explaining the concept in
2014 let's start with this in 2014 you
can hold down the phone the button on
your phone and you can speak into it and
set a reminder yeah which is by the way
the only way I have ever attempted to
use Siri well and I will say one thing
being a person who is usually around
when link is reminding himself of
something
I told Siri I'm totally sure you can do
lots of things I've never attempted
anything he is horrible at setting
reminders I the other day I watched him
or listen to him try to remind himself
about something I don't remember what it
was he never ended up reminding himself
of it said I think it was set on alarm
so we go surfing but in 2014 we do a
thing called surfing you you missed like
every every she got everything wrong and
she like asked you if you wanted to do a
web search about
surfing or something I she did not
respond well your thing that happens is
in 2014
I'll hold down this button and then I'll
be like Siri set my alarm for 5:00 a.m.
and then it will it will be like I'll
well if we started talking too early and
then it did it work it works
oh whoa she did it first of all I should
delete that one why don't we go wake up
at 5:00 a.m. but for the longest time I
would I would start talking too late and
I would say I don't understand yeah
but that and that's the struggles of
2014 now but do you have you ever talked
to your phone another way cuz I think
that would be a good thing to put it in
the time capsule yeah I asked the phone
questions you asked it like um yet the
serie where's the nearest taco upstairs
in the refrigerator what is it what is
she she well she says there are 17
restaurants within 2 miles that serve
tacos
she's probably right the nearest taco
you you haven't asked her right well
yeah ask her right now Siri where is the
nearest taco do you have to say Siri
Taco Bell store locator okay del Taco
locations those are not the best tacos
within I didn't say the best I said the
nearest oh she knows what's up where is
the best taco Pirie okay so that's my
contribution voice activation yeah and I
and let me just make a little prediction
to see how Nostradamus IM i assume that
in this when the first reminder dings in
2024 voice that your conversations with
your phone will just be not not like
talking to a person i don't think it's
there yet but surely you just talk to
phone normally right now when we want to
tell the phone something we'd be we have
to speak very clearly I don't think
that's your gonna talk to your phone in
a demeaning fashion like you're talking
to a person who can't hear very well I
never noticed this before but when you
enunciate like that your mustache dances
yeah well we could talk a little bit
about it's pretty cool our style it
currently I do have a mustache and it's
attached to a full beard in two places I
die on either side of your mouth yeah
it's a symmetrical beard I should
describe you okay and you describe me so
move the mic a little bit okay as if you
really need a reference 2014 Rhett has a
must as we said a mustache attached to a
beard in two places on either side of
his mouth yeah and he's got a pretty
long nose I don't think much of that's
gonna change are you assuming they're
not gonna be able to like your nose is
it gonna get shorter they're not gonna
be able to just search for pictures of
like Rhett mcLaughlin 2014 why should
why should they don't me they're
listening to me alright painted panel
panel lecture a mental picture at this
point Rhett still has two eyes well
instead of prediction yeah
I'm implying that something's gonna have
and his hair his hair goes up and I see
one I do see one wrinkle on your
forehead I'm just gonna say it
really oh when your eyebrows go up it
comes to different yeah a bunch
I'd call that a smile line I would call
that a display when I'm smiling right
well I call it an expression line I
wouldn't call it a wrinkle so I'm gonna
give you the benefit of the doubt there
and that's about it you're wearing
headphones right now but you typically
do that I'm I'm really good at making a
time capsule worthless time cash he's
currently wearing headphones describe me
you have on glasses there are a pair of
glasses that you recently acquired I'd
say in the past couple of months we've
made a really big deal out about about
it on good mythical morning glasses
signify smarts okay and style in the in
the year 2014 glasses make you smarter
and you had but interestingly hipster
man I'll just go ahead and say you have
a hipster pair of glasses you have a
pair of glasses styled in like a 1950's
manner which is you know horn-rimmed a
little bit but a little but also has a
taste of modernity and it's and they're
pretty stylish they're two-tone they
have it like an hombre like they've been
dipped into the Sun on the bottom but
it's a subtle color change I picture
some police catching spending a lot of
time on your glasses you might be able
to just Google a picture okay support my
comment and interesting thing though is
the word hipster is still thrown around
a lot that's been happening for the past
six and a half years yeah the word
hipster it's a little derogatory and
usually but we but worse we will call
ourselves that gladly but people use it
derogatorily but and they don't the
people who do that don't really know
what it means you're right and neither
do I really I don't have a beard I'm
drinking water out of out of a mug right
now mugs mugs are still in use
all right news in 2014 in perspective
okay go ahead you I see
pull you put your hair up on your
forehead thank you you I'd say you have
a little wrinkle a little line there
yeah yeah definitely in the middle but
no nowhere else eat nowhere else you
look relatively young everywhere else
your beard is strong its I mean it's
like it's not there but it wants to come
out like it looks like the follicles are
strong your eyes are blue probably gonna
stay the same I'm hoping your hair is uh
black looks a little like a brown dark
brown looks a little like a Thelma from
scooby-doo and but I can't really see
that right now because you have
headphones on but from a fashion
perspective let's let's go a little
serious here I mean you wearing a
collared shirt with some ducks or
something flying on it right he goes she
goes this is fashionably questionable at
this point
I got a compliment on this shirt tonight
twice from a fashion I mean you got
skinny jeans yeah I do
I we saw you we do that we're criticized
in Internet comments about that but
skinny jeans are a thing that's
happening amongst hipsters I can't even
I can't even think even now when I think
back 10 years 15 years 20 years about
how big jeans used to be what going back
15 years we had on jeans that my entire
waist could fit in the knee easily like
Genco jeans he could wear a lag of jeans
and now we wear jeans I really can't
even get my legs in properly you know
it's really it I admit that it's
pathetic and impractical but I just I'm
a slave to the see yourself because
you're self-conscious of it but in 10
years enough it may have come back again
is that enough time it could be tights
ten years from now or it could be lusus
it could be really loose it could go
back to that I think officially not a
lot of fishin C is important in the
future I believe that men and women all
wear tights so those of you are
listening in 24 20 24 in your tights
Aloha that's a common greeting now for
hello but no not now in 2024 right but
just clarifying now it just makes me
think of Hawaii right it's distinct it
is distinctly Hawaiian to say a 2014
prediction in 2024 it'll be the common
world of greeting skinny ties skinny
ties are still in but on the way out I
was actually just looking at my tie
collection to make a decision about the
what we're gonna wear to the streamys
which at the time we were gonna wear
what we have to think about yeah I think
I'm wearing a skinny yeah and I believe
that it's a correct choice if you were a
little fashion-forward and you're pretty
fashion or more fashion-forward than I
am but if you were even more fashion for
than you are you would have a short fat
tie and I'm not I'm not blowing smoke
I'm that's coming back skinny ties are
still yeah that's what they're selling
but I'm saying within 12 months fat like
so see like that only comes to like
halfway down the shirt
order and fatter like revealing the
whole belt oh yes definitely hmm what
are ties like in 2024 bolos in like
rodeo communities maybe no I think bolos
are a common practice it business
business affairs are lots of lots of
bolos every everything fits very snug
now all the men have on bolos in tights
I'm president Aloha I'm not gonna try to
predict okay a time capsule the point of
a time capsule is not to see how off we
are about the future there well there
are no rules that time capsule what a
bats hats I'm glad you asked this
question because you may have noticed
those of you in the present 2020 for
2014 sorry that I have taken a couple of
pictures have been featured in a couple
of videos but via the Facebook and
Instagram that kind of thing where I'm
wearing a hat yes I have a hat you're
dabbling in hat äj--
yeah and I've never been a fan of hats
but I'm talking like a baseball hat well
that's because we were developing a
mythical hat we are that's a nice way
for an announcement news break in 2014 I
think later this this year we will have
unveiled the first mythical hat which
ten years from now will be all the rage
yeah of course and we're not joking
about the mythical hat and that's that's
true literally that's why you've been
wearing a hat well so that you could
whenever we sell a hat you can the first
hat you wear won't be your own hat yeah
is that just yeah Andrew from tweek who
works with us on developing products
brought in some sample hats and tried on
all of them and I found one that I
thought worked and it definitely is a
flat brim hat it's a high crown flat
brim kind of a newt we call that new era
style it's sort of an urban look and
that is what I'm supporting now and i've
been criticized for it again the same
people who criticize you for skinny
jeans will criticize you for the flat
bill hats they say it looks ridiculous
and it may but i think that it looks
better it is a it is a fashion state it
is what's in style now to wear a hat
would and don't don't bend the brim and
and the part that covers your head crown
tall the crown is higher that's called a
high crown I wore one of those sample
hats home and my family all said I was
wearing to wrap her hat yeah a rapper
hat that's another term that's what my
kids think of it but they did my
daughter is 11 she will be 21 when this
time capsule is opened she'll be of
drinking age but no but the drinking age
will probably have changed
yeah the drinking age in 2014 is 21
years old in America
um robots really suck in 2014 oh yeah we
would have everyone think we're so
frustrated the frustration surrounding
robots in this current 2014 is palpable
uh well I would say it's it's it's kind
of under the surface but whenever
seething you get anyone talking about
robots they all agree robots
suck we watch YouTube videos breathing
nastiness into someone's face just
saying robot we we watch YouTube videos
of robots but you know we watch them to
see the robots fall and fail that's
that's what we because there's robots in
Japan that can run well if you want to
come using quotes around run a Simo will
run a little bit but and maybe go up
some stairs but he'll fall down - but
he's not running to do anything now he's
running to show you here on in 2024 I
hope I really hope he's running to
something he's really door every running
to get your kid he's babysitting the
children he's running to catch a ball
yeah doing whatever a CMO does or mr.
robot in 2024 so robots suck currently
we're not happy at all with that remote
control cars have not changed a whole
lot the past 30 years I'm frustrated
about that - yeah but not that much and
I'm like my kids have remote-control
cars and they are no different than the
remote-control cars I had when I was
their age I think they've peaked I think
about 23 do you think they're the same
RC vehicles peaked
okay your decide okay whatever I mean
you could be right they definitely have
not changed
wearable stuff Google glass is still
like something that people talk about
but nobody has it or uses it no one that
I know but we like we like to talk about
that Google glass yeah yeah like talking
about it puts us in the future yeah it
makes us excited like if if you didn't
have a podcast where you could make a
time capsule and like you know ramble on
and anally like we are what you would be
doing in 2014 is talking about Google
glass like just drop it like you're
mentioning it did you hear about Rob I
hear he's one of the guys that got the
Google glass and we got our hands on
this thing and when it came here to our
studio we for the nervous geek rap
battle like the team was passing around
a lot using it for a second nobody could
figure out how to use it no no by the
time I got to me I didn't even I didn't
even put it on you gave up before you
get started I wasn't he after watching
other people on the Google glass yeah I
was like I don't I'm not even interested
in trying and you'll notice that we say
the Google glass we put of the in front
of it 14 I I did wear the Google glass
and I I took a video that's how I said
it I took a video like taking a picture
but it's a video and that means I
recorded a video and I actually voice
commanded the video to begin recording
and then was able to wash it back I
would say it was it was a thrilling
experience it was it was a one-time
thing I haven't been back to it I mean
we had to give the Google glass back but
that's where it is right now having
something around your eyes like a
glasses or whatever a monocle or a watch
or like having something around your
wrist that could be like oh this is an
Apple watch or suppose well
interestingly when we're recording this
next week is the the rumored
announcement of the
the iWatch not that it's going to be
immediately available for sale but that
Apple is going to announce that I watch
and and and I think a couple of other
brands already have a SmartWatch or
whatever but of course Apple doing it is
a bigger deal and everyone's excited
about it but it's it's the fact that
we're going to have a watch that has the
functionality and the technology of our
phones currently this is an exciting
idea in 2014 we're excited about this we
are I mean I looked at the you know the
the pictures the theoretical pictures of
the eye watch and immediately said yes I
will have one of these and you're
willing to pay how much in 2014 dollars
for it
they said it was gonna be $300 I was
thinking people will gladly pay $350 for
it yeah of course and I don't even know
what it will do I don't care what it
will do if it does half of what my phone
does and it's on my wrist as a fashion
device I'll be pleased
we do have Holograms in 2014 but again I
mean it's it's they did a Tupac hologram
like two years ago and at Coachella and
then they did a Michael Jackson hologram
at the Grammys I think and that's that's
pretty much the extent of holograms so
we're frustrated holo thing right this
again a very to me personally it's like
maybe if you can't make a good robot at
least make a good holographic robot yeah
I feel very similar about robots and
Holograms because these are things that
have been in all of our movies all of
our sci-fi stories for so so long but
the only way we can experience a
hologram is by being in a crowd and
being at a certain angle you know what
I'm talking about is a watch that makes
a hologram you know what I mean like a
Star Wars situation oh yeah
or even just a hologram in my in one
room in my home I think the reason why
this isn't going to come
to pass in 10 20 or 30 years is because
it's not it's an illusion well so as a
television screen so it's for
entertainment only
there's no either see I mean I see I'm
expressing the 2014 cinema a popular
sentiment at least from from my camp
their popular system it is that my own
brain holograms are not that appealing
and therefore not as frustrating to not
be that great because they just have
novel entertainment value so if you're
laughing right now 10 20 30 years from
now it's because you experience
Holograms in a way that enriches your
life beyond frivolous entertainment so I
have no clue how you're doing it yeah
something you can intercept I'm very
envious of I cannot anticipate well I
can't just wait one thing like a
physical relations with a with a
hologram well that's not exactly what I
was thinking that is an interesting
thought though what I was thinking was
not a hawk it was relational it was you
know Skype chat like ala Graham with
someone that you love why were a
therapist yeah and because mic therapy
is expensive oh yes
holographic therapy not as expensive
occasion videoconferencing you know you
remember the other day when we were in
that videoconference in the room and
they brought the two people in on the
screens yeah hey we haven't talked about
that since that happened the first time
that's ever happened
felt like the president you know what I
mean while I was at Google yeah I mean
we can say that did that was a yeah at
that we were at the Google YouTube
headquarter yeah conference room and
they started googling in people it was
amazing but in the future 2024 sit in a
chair dude sitting in a chair and that
but that's what the movies tell you but
but think about
got to be better than that he didn't
have the the people on the screens in
that meeting you know I didn't take him
seriously cuz there on a screen they're
not in the room with us but as soon as
they're a hologram sitting right there
across even just because I can put my
face through their face and they don't
know it doesn't does it mean that I
shouldn't listen to them Bob I disagree
with your point I'm coming over there to
put my face through your holographic
face I am facing you right now and by
facing - I mean I'm embedding my face in
your face that's a common insult in 2024
is what you face someone who is a
hologram put your face into their
holograph or just say just sit right
where they are
oh that's even I think you might get
burned maybe they're usually blue so
they're very cold these are all things
we currently think I'm just being I'm
just being raw with y'all 10 20 30 years
from now I know I know we sounds stupid
but right in 2014 we don't sound stupid
at all yeah we sound like prophets no
we're just being honest yeah well I
guess we are speculating about that we
have television screens at gas pumps yes
we do and I filled up an hour ago and I
was done filling up and it occurred to
me I haven't looked at this television
screen the whole time I've been here oh
I've never looked at one of those and I
remember thinking as a youngster one day
there will be television screens on gas
pumps and out and it will be amazing and
what did you think it would be though
like Fresh Prince of bel-air playing on
there cuz I might watch it if that was
the case yeah I might just pull up a
chair and spend 22 minutes in front of
the gala they've got to keep the content
short it was just an ad because they
don't want to lock you in and be like it
was ads yeah yeah this guy is sitting
there watching Law & Order SVU that is a
show that's on right now I think one of
the things that the sci-fi movies of the
80s got right was that there's you're
gonna be advertised to everywhere
through screens
and what I'm saying is it's happening we
know and I'm already inoculated to it
yeah yeah that it definitely seemed that
still seems futuristic to us yeah it's
not it is that one in every 40 gas
station experiences you'll get a yeah
there's like a person talking and ad
going and it's very much like Back to
the Future when there was a billboard
that was a screen and we were like wow
that's awesome yeah I didn't even think
about that the billboards will be TV
screens oh well we get we got that
already yeah we have that so not that
what's gonna be at your gas pump you
know I get well and your we also drive
our own vehicles yeah oh yeah yeah we
are in charge of where we go now just in
the past couple of years they've the
debate over self-driving cars is really
started oh yeah emphasis on debate like
no one agrees yeah whether it whether
it's actually gonna tell the average
person right now if you just were to ask
the average person what do you think
about self-driving cars they'd be like I
don't trust them I don't trust them even
though it is statistically proven
already that the number of accidents
will be dramatically reduced with
self-driving cars it doesn't the facts
don't matter facts don't matter to most
people anyway and they probably still
don't matter in 2024 2014 the facts
about self-driving cars don't matter to
people because everybody's scared of
them and thinks it's gonna be some sort
of big brother thing where we're all
gonna be like wrecked into each other by
computer overlord
but I am a but they've just passed
legislation and I think it was the UK
basically saying that you know
self-driving cars are gonna be allowed
to go a certain amount above the speed
limit when they like anticipating yeah
they're gonna be out there so I'm
assuming about 2020 for self-driving
cars are normal you look over and
there's a dude napping or texting
because right now texting while driving
big no-no when we drive for this whole
video about this rightfully so yeah it's
on par with
driving in our in our society but I'm
assuming that you're texting and
drinking and sleeping all at the same
time while your car drives you around at
2024 but now what will happen is someone
will do something you don't like and
you'll look at the person in the vehicle
and you'll have anger towards them and
sometimes you might yell at them
sometimes they may yell back and like
there'll be this exchange which might
involve like hand gestures road rage
yeah that happens today because as a
result of us being in charge of our own
via because you know it's the losers
fault when he pulls them for out in
front of you it tastes fault not as cars
right you've got you've got a you've got
a target for your you can just take out
your anger your frustration on this
person because they're copal yeah and we
it's they're responsible and typically
what happens in that situation is we
extend the middle finger
it's called flipping the bird I used to
understand that as flicking the bird
growing up in North Carolina as a child
I flick a crumb you know that bird right
you kind of flick it if you think about
it you're flicking it up there I did
learn is a teenager that it was flip of
the bird and that's what we call it
typically today right we've all been
agreement on that for many years and
said for you
welcome to that yeah it's not flicking
the bird you know at this point I'm
thinking a couple of thoughts about
what's what this show can I just step
back for a second sure and just make
some observations about this time cause
like two first one is I would love more
than ever for this to be a call-in show
right now like coast to coast yeah I
would I feel like why don't we do that I
feel like I'm totally serious right now
I would like to I would like to and this
may be the birth of an idea I haven't I
just want to hear what America what the
world I want to hear what the world has
to say right now about like everyone
called in and tell us one thing to add
to the audio time capsule just what a
great idea I would love that right now
link occasionally has great ideas in 24
days I'm assuming he has them all the
time in 2024 you know what 2014 we don't
have technology we cannot do a call-in
show
yeah we could we could my second thing
is if as I listened to myself now in
2014 or put myself in the seat of a
listener in current times hologram as it
watches something I feel like this is
potentially the lamest episode of ear
biscuits ever because we're we're
talking about things that everybody
knows about
we're just saying things that it's it's
like listening to to listen in on a
conversation between two guys and you're
just uh yeah yeah every the reaction
everything is yeah that's why I'm doing
slightly predictive things but you're
trying to make it I mean yeah mix it up
a little bit okay
well let's let's keep going but another
thing about the present is we recently
both watched a movie called her it is
it's always got an Antonio Banderas
feast is guy named Joaquin Phoenix
something I could not say for a long
time Joaquin is still alive to knit ten
years from megastar
but anyway talented guy movie written
and directed by Spike Jones we both
absolutely love this movie a lot of
people did not we acknowledge that but
we both loved it and it was fascinating
remember her that's what I'm trying to
tell you ten years from now you just say
there's a movie her don't you remember
it and they would be like yes well you
might not okay her is all about and I'm
saying this for the sake of the present
people in 2014 that may have not seen a
movie okay
Joaquin's feigning Phoenix's Joaquin
Phoenix Joaquin Phoenix rises from the
ashes no 20 30 years from now the lead
character falls in love with an
operating system played by Scarlett
Johansson as her voice originally played
by an English actress and they redid the
whole movie after they'd recorded
everything with Scarlett Johansson
Sports fun fact that's probably still
true ten years from now anyway he has in
he has a very emotional emotionally
significant relationship with this
computer who for all intents and
purposes is a
person they are not they are not a
person like a human but they embody a
personality and it's Syria to the max in
a way that I do not believe it will be
the case in 2024 I cannot believe that
there really I mean then not it not
close 10 years is not a long time no
it's not yeah yeah well I mean when my
daughter is 21 years old do I want her
to have a relationship like a romantic
relationship with a copper ating system
you put more so than them within a boy
maybe so then wanna think about it right
yeah but I'm still thinking about it
I still don't know I still don't know
there's lots of question marks
associated with that but my son can just
but I mean so most of our relationships
are limited to flesh and blood we have
no significant relationships with any
digital entities and there is not there
is no conversation about the nature of
personhood when it comes to a digital
entity hmm
which was which was obviously one of the
say about yeah you can think that that
will happen well of course because
there'll be a point in which
consciousness if there is an artificial
intelligence I'm not saying a soul but a
consciousness right but there are many
people who would say that the soul is
the consciousness so so in that was that
was is what defines soul is what some
people would say now in 2024 we're
probably not we're probably having this
debate this what we're talking about is
probably an interesting ethics question
in every introductory ethics class but
where you know how far are we from the
from the her situation I don't know
probably another maybe another 10 years
maybe 20 30 for their significant
relationships with digital entities
oh and we don't a digital president
maybe mmm that's boy I say I'd say
that's 2044
digital president digital president well
I think what about digital dead relative
are you voting for the president or you
are you voting for the digital president
the first digital president ever Digital
dead relative so when you die but I mean
what what what we're hopeful about is
not that we get to like live forever
like cryogenically or you know discover
the Pan's Labyrinth or whatever lease
eternity the the Fountain of Youth
yeah thought of you Tree of Life maybe I
just got Pan's Labyrinth and fountain of
you discovers the Pan's elaborate and
elaborate is a movie it's not labyrinth
starring David Bowie but what I want
Pan's Labyrinth and later movie what I
what I usable is that we will have
digital entities of ourselves so that
when we pass away that they can live on
for the sake of our relative so
operating systems will not just be
fabricated they will be simulations of
dead relatives and how does that idea
seem to you as a 2014 man it seems sad
because I don't experience it I'm just
doing it for like my loved ones to
continue to relate to me what they even
want to but if the contents of your
brain could be offloaded onto another
device would that be a conscience would
that be your conscience that continue to
experience things even though the real
you had passed on I mean you think about
it again if we had Collins at this point
and someone called in who knew about
this stuff they could probably say think
about it for a second if you take a ship
a boat and you take all the cargo No and
over time that boat breaks down
you replace each piece of wood and after
a hundred years you've replaced that
boat with a completely new boat is it
still the boat or is it the new pieces
of wood that make the boat you know
every nine years or so every one of
yourselves and your body is replaced
right so are you still the same you is
you being offloaded to a hard drive no
longer you know it is not me it's
digital link and I mean because it's the
rate of change of the planks of the boat
what if this career continues for the
next day all if all the planks change it
once is a different boat okay what but
if they but if the percentage of planks
that swap at any one point are is lower
than middle 10%
okay the total boat plank egde is still
the boat then it it keeps its bonus
intact what if you Sydney bonus sit in
someone's hologram do you become them no
you just you get incinerated because
those things are hot
they're blue butts are hot like the hot
you know blue is the hottest color at
Harrah's and here's another question it
was the hottest part of the flame right
now we're a comedic duo we have been for
quite a quite some time we anticipate
that this will continue indefinitely at
least ten years and but is there a point
in which the technology is at a place
where we could just create a digital
rhett and Link and they could do all the
work again I think you'd come up with
the ideas I think this is 100-year
material this is not 10-year man it
hundred years man you're into just
thinking it happens territory you know
no no differentiation unless of course
there's some sort of cataclysmic event
that just puts all technology at a halt
then all bets are off
okay credit cards we still use credit
cards I've got one
in my pocket a stack of them in my
pocket debit credit all different types
business personal and they're all just
plastic cards you remember them future
people with a magnetic strip on them
that gets worn off over time and then
when it gets worn off the people that
you give them to at the stores we go to
stores to buy things they have to type
in the number in this little contraption
that uses a phone line a landline to
make a call to some server somewhere to
like let the transaction go through
that's how credit cards work now there
are some places that have a little
device that plugs into an iPad or iPhone
that is connected to it to a digital
network and you and it doesn't work
through a phone line but either way it
still is this piece of plastic that we
take out and give to someone clearly
that will not be happening 10 years from
now but what will it be is it gonna be
the dreaded chip in the body I don't
think I mean it was in the next few
years it will be in your phone it's just
gonna be in whatever digital wearable
tech that you have Apple pay thing or a
Google Wallet or on your phone or on
your on your glasses on your head to be
a it'll be a blue punch it'll be a short
range yeah
transfer of mecir ease of numbers
associated with your credit card but for
right now we still sit on a stack of
plastic that whenever we purchase
anything you got to fumble it out and
find the right one you want to use and
some people say I don't use that one
with that logo mm-hmm and you got to get
the other one with the other logo and
then in certain places over a certain
amount you have to sign you should you
use an ink pen I think that we're in a
some good stuff right now because this
is gonna seem nutso and not to our
future you buy something we give you our
classics then you give it back to us
after you call the phone you've use a
phone on through some machine you give
it back to us and then along with a
sheet of paper and an ink pen an actual
pin that you write with
you hold it in your hand and you sign
your name but you you sign your name on
the back and technically it's supposed
to match the signature that you've
written on the plastic card and the way
they know that it's you is if the
signatures match but no one in America
at least ever checks it and sometimes in
Europe they still do for the most part
they ask you for your ID which is
another piece of plastic that says who
you are it's not your DNA signature it's
nothing physical about you it's just a
plastic piece of plastic
but it has your picture and discuss your
picture on it yeah you can make it in a
3d printer and it's like you know stop
the presses oh he is who he is because
of this plastic card he's got with
himself what an idiotic concept that we
are experiencing in 2014
yeah I but I am starting to get
perturbed when I have when they give me
the little sheet of paper and I have to
sign it like what's the meaning of this
nothing it's it is meaningless which is
why it will be laughable or you can just
reach in the other pocket and pull out
wads of paper and coinage you don't have
this right on it just hand on that you
know right on anything they still hand
you something back but you don't have to
write on it there's no writing right
girl there's writing like printed on the
paper itself which is made out of cotton
by the way it's not even paper it's made
out of cotton you can wash it in the in
the washing machine and you go to stores
to buy things but I mean I'm just
getting to the point where if I want
something I'm gonna go to Amazon I'm
gonna use Amazon Prime because I don't
have to pay for shipping Oh which brings
up another interesting thing as we're
right now in the talking about drones
now every drones are really popular
people use them it's you know it's the
thing to put a little camera on a drone
and get some video footage it's like
whoa are you a helicopter pilot
so another that's got a drone it's like
really small I got it for $300 I put a
GoPro on it and then I just put it in
the air and it's like I got a big job or
some sort of crazy like helicopter but
it for a realist like
or dollars man if it runs out of
batteries it has just enough battery to
come back to me yeah I won't even crush
ya if it gets lost it just comes back to
where it let where it launched it's
really cool it's like a smart drone so
that's the situation with drones now I
drink redbull but what's being debated
specifically now is Amazon and probably
Google Google Amazon uses drones but
Google has this thing that looks like a
winged a white stealth fighter that are
you talking about 2014 yes I'm talking
about 2014 you haven't seen the Google
wing it's there it's there proposed
drone yes their drone and it it looks
like a stealth fighter none of these
things are in use right now I do want to
clarify
well there's prototypes but no they're
not in use but right now we're my wife
and I had a conversation the other day
and out and she was like do you know
that they're gonna have these drones and
if we'll order something from Amazon
Prime and it will show up in the front
yard like within 24 hours from a drone
and we have this conversation like that
won't happen because somebody might get
hit with a propeller or something that's
you know a dog is gonna get hit by
propeller that'll never happen
but yeah I have to make these wrong the
drone will never happen because the dog
will definitely get hit with a propeller
and there's how we think but there's
lots of people who think that there's
something unconstant aliy wrong
unconstitutional about the drones and
they've got cameras on them and
everybody knew that you know you can't
do anything in private anymore that's a
big deal III think that that debate will
be over over yeah I mean they probably
said the same thing about Google Earth
and so well there's cameras going all of
them down the street and then it's
published on the internet and I didn't
give any permission for that and people
get fired from their jobs because of
things they put on Facebook like there's
oh did you hear about the teacher who
got fired because she puts a personal
picture of herself doing this on face
book or whatever I don't like though
that happens and you know people like to
talk about it yeah people like tell me
did you hear about so-and-so who got
fired because of their what their
Facebook photo so there's there's that
people just not knowing what how
Facebook works and getting fired over it
like know what not knowing that someone
else could see these things right but
talking about drones you know I do think
that most people in the in the distant
past will say the 80s would have just
assumed by the year 2014 that when you
looked up into the air you would see all
these little planes going over flying
cars you know and that cars and I do
think that the the combination of the
major barrier to personal flight devices
besides the cost barrier the price of
the technology is the traffic right air
traffic control it's like what are you
how what are you supposed to do how do
you not just run into each other
Doherty's wheel lanes where you put the
yellow lines in the sky right but smart
smart driving you know self-driving
takes care of that because the computer
can think about a billion different
things at once right so once you have
the the the drones are cheaper large
enough to hold a person but small enough
but they gotta hold on really tight and
there's enough of them that they're not
the price point isn't too high the point
of entry isn't too high and you combine
that with smart driving I think there
will be just a lot of people flying all
over the place but I don't think it's
gonna be a 22 24 34 in 2020 for the big
news story is gonna be the toddler who
hitched a ride on a drone right how did
she went to let Amazon headquarters
little Randy was found back at their
will Amazon warehouse yeah and you know
in the you know and lingerie section
right exactly
yeah he was he was buried in lingerie
and we asked him what had happened he
said I just grabbed on I grabbed rum I'm
going to just do this flying machine boy
he has a good grip though
yeah and he's he's known as the boy with
the iron grip and he goes on to host
game shows well okay must be a guest on
game shows no he he's like why would it
be a good host
oh oh it's Randy
yes his name was Randy I'm the kid who
grabbed onto the drum kid with the iron
grip here that I get what year 2024 okay
that's gonna happen 10 years from I
think that's probably to happen next
year yeah drone stowaways first it'll be
like a cat or a snake or something and
then it'll be a little toddler a snake I
can see that snake on the drum snakes
unemploy snake on a drone it's not a
feature film it's a tube video speaking
of which
sharknado was big this year I haven't
seen a sharknado 2 to be more
specifically sharknado already done a
second one big last year or maybe the
year before sharknado 2 yeah and this is
the idea of a tornado which is really a
hurricane picking up a bunch of sharks
and depositing them into cities which
but it's intentionally it was
intentionally stupid even at the time
but it was embraced as awesome oh yeah
and then celebrated with a second with a
second go-round which brings us to video
entertainment the way that we enjoy non
Holograms
we do enjoy 3d in the movie theater some
people have it at home but those people
are few and far between yeah even if you
I mean when we went to Disneyland and
they had the 3d shows those were like
wow whatever because now every
blockbuster movie that's got any action
or any 3d and it's an mesmerizing 3d by
my standards that Disneyland no longer
meets so no one goes to those rides and
they don't and of course 10 years from
now those rides will not exist
at Disneyland oh yeah like a 3d right
wet I got my televisions 3d yeah right
and I you know we so we got all movies
will be 3d but I mean that's that's the
thing when it comes to movies and most
of the reason that we go to the movies
well there's twofold in 2014 we the
movie is released in the theatres first
right that's when it's released in the
theatres and then after a certain period
of time it's released on DVD like we
still get I like I don't know what the
time it's probably like three months
later you're watching on Netflix yeah
direct yeah direct direct to some video
streaming service and that's how we
enjoy most of our movies but everyone's
well I'm like the kids we're gonna go
watch a 3d movie we're going to the
theater I think that the my prediction
is that the movie watching experience
will be such at home will be so
comparable or even better than what we
would get in a theater now that the the
people will have had to upgrade what the
theater provides in 2024 and I think
that we're definitely in the realm of
smellivision don't laugh you know air
being played on the Disneyland stuff
they when you do that certain ride you
smell certain things and then they like
poke you in the back of the head through
the seat and they shoot stuff out and
they sprinkle water on you
I definitely think all that's got to
happen in a in the normal movie theater
for people to go to the movies in 2025 I
thought you saying smellivision is gonna
be at in your home you could probably be
yeah I think at the cartridges so sure
it is I'm not willing to pay for the
color cartridge in my inkjet printer I'm
definitely not paying for a refill the
smellivision cartridges I think it goes
a long way have to go into that
television I think you will I'm sure
ingredients pumped into those cartridges
to like produce everything from a fart
to a day so it's like a box of crayons
man I mean is you mixing max match once
you smell smell-o-vision link in your
own home you will think where have you
been all my life and you will
immediately sign up for the subscription
service there will be no this is I this
is
worth it I mean they're printing
chocolate now man I don't even have a
burning chocolate now I don't even have
DVR TiVo if I want to watch something on
television I actually I still sit
through commercials which which
subsidize the production of televisions
you are but you are behind the time I
know you are in like 2000 I know that
but television this is 2014 commercials
still subsidized subsidized what's
happening on television that's still a
thing because they haven't figured out
how television shows can be subsidized
otherwise other ways of course we've
figured out how to subsidize the type of
content that we do now but we can't do
television esque shows on YouTube that
are as good as what you might see on
like a Breaking Bad which i think is an
interesting thing and it may be an
interesting way to close this thing down
is that we make youtube videos which
people do enjoy on their televisions if
they are a little more tech savvy but in
general we still see YouTube as a
different entity from television from it
as a different entity from internet
television as a different entity from
movies yeah and YouTube is on my
television as an app but you don't you
don't sit down and enjoy YouTube I might
I might sit down and enjoy YouTube on my
television while I wait for Christie to
like get out of the bathroom and sit
down so that we can watch something on
Netflix or Amazon like a show like a
longer show like okay for instance a
week ago or so we had the Emmys the
television awards right and so the
series that were up for best show or
whatever you know Breaking Bad Mad Men
Game of Thrones these kinds of things
these are not things that people these
are things that people enjoy through
services like Netflix but you know
tonight we went to a streaming reception
and there are shows that are being
awarded thing
our YouTube shows differently different
things like good mythical morning we
didn't win anything but they're just
very different in the eye of the people
who are entertained by them the eyes of
the public everybody says oh they're
these things are merging right YouTube
and TV they're just kind of becoming
it's all becoming one thing and but the
best thing we can point to is that at
the Video Music Awards there was an
internet category which explained that
well it is what you just said people are
considered I think they they call them
vlogging stars or something I can't
really do music it's not a music video
well that's just the VMAs there's all
kinds of Awards of that I know that was
it no that was the People's Choice no it
was the Teen Choice Awards yeah I'm the
Choice Awards another VMAs yeah well
okay
that's a little bit better but still we
know that they've merged because Teen
Choice Awards now have internet
celebrities as are like a part of the
award ceremony but they call them
internet celebrities and so my
prediction is that while I think that
there will be just something distinctly
different about these sort of
independent entertainment and in the
form of you know something service like
YouTube and then there'll be studio
based but it's not going to be well one
is on this website and one is on my TV
when I get home it comes to it I think
that distinction is going away but I
don't think and I don't want the
distinction between independent minded
or independently financed things and
then to be different from studio based
things network based things that
probably is not going to go away mm-hmm
and another thing in 2014 we just talked
for an hour about stuff that if you're
listening to it now you already knew
because you're living it right now but
if you're listening to this 10 20 30 40
50 60 70 100 years from now well your
your mind is increasingly blown
with the mundane subject matters that
we've just got you to listen to for the
past hour and I thank you for that and
let me just say this to those of you
listening 100 years from now no doubt
you are experiencing this not over the
course of one hour you are experiencing
this as a download in the blink of an
eye that was immediately added to the
information that is in your brain that
is both human and you know ceramic or
something is this like standard download
curriculum for all humans on the earth
planet Wow we've arrived and I'm
horrible this is the link this let me
tell you some time capsule what we are
doing in the year 30 14 know 21 14 sorry
not a thousand years from now only a
hundred years now is almost pointless
because a hundred years from now not
only will you be able to download
information instantaneously like this
podcast but you will be able to access
all the information that has ever
existed instantaneously I mean will
instantaneously know it yes you will
you're Bionic Lee supported brain will
be able to instantly take all the data
that's ever been created and synthesize
it and experience it and everyone will
basically be exactly equal so that's
like inserting another plank on the boat
yeah do you know what I'm you going I'm
getting at so what I'm getting at is
every meet every piece of media that we
have made are making it will make will
be instantaneously instantaneously
experienced by everyone at the same time
by no effort at all how does that make
you feel well
the destination is the journey that
makes me sad yeah it does I you know
what and for those of you 100 years from
now who've made the decision that you
want to unplug from that you don't want
that to be your existence that good for
you you want to disengage from the
matrix good for you yes we wish we could
be there with you to join the the rebels
to just be like let's get back to
humanity let's get back to processing
information through sight and sound and
smell and touch
I hope my seed makes that choice your
seed my progeny okay yeah and to our
great great grandchildren who are
listening to this my seed join the
rebels because experiencing life through
the five senses is an amazing thing it
doesn't need to go away you know even
though it means you're gonna lose the
ability to process this or access this
podcast at any moment in time it is okay
because you can access it in what is
called a memory which is in the natural
mind and that is a beautiful thing
hashtag your best kids let us know what
you think about this episode
maybe we'll get it trending in 2024
stack here [ __ ] is that a thing then
alright guys here from his next week
[Music]
[Music]